TWENTY TELL ME THE AUGUST
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE ISIN
SESSION. I BELIEVE WE NEED
SEVEN FOR A QUORUM. THIS
EVENING IS AT SEVEN MARK. WE
NEED EIGHT TO MEMBERS WON'T BE
HERE. I DON'T I CAN'T REMEMBER
WHICH TO WHAT THERE'S TWO THAT
ARE. VOEPEL OUR MEDICAL WITH
THAT YES. SO THE AMOUNT OF. THE
WORST REGARDLESS WE NEED SEVEN
RIGHT. EIGHT EIGHT WE NEED
EIGHT. WHAT WE COULD DO IS
START TO HEAR THE BILL'S. WE
WILL MORE MISTER CHAIR. MISTER
CHEN WELCOME SIR. LET ME READ
THE- REQUIRED LANGUAGE HERE AND
THEN WE'LL BRING UP MISS
BOERNER HORVATH DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STAY AT HOME ORDER
WE'RE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. DO I NEED TO READ ALL
THIS LANGUAGE. AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE'RE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE ARE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASKS BE WORN AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE IT MAINTAINED BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR THE VIDEO CONFERENCING
SITE. IF YOU DON'T HAVE A MASK
WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU.
BECAUSE THE SPACE LIMITATIONS
IN THIS ROOM WE HAVE SOME
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SITTING AT
THE DíAS AND OTHER SITTING IN
THE FIRST FEW ROWS OF SEATS IN
THE AUDIENCE. FOR THOSE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK DURING THE
HEARING PLEASE APPROACH THE
MIKE BEHIND THE PLEXIGLAS. AND
PLEASE REMEMBER TO PRACTICE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESSES TESTIFYING TODAY. FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM. IF ANY
MEMBER THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
I'LL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC.
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU
CONNECTS THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING RETURN
YOUR C. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING. LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF ONE OF
OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS.
AND A FEW OTHER LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONYLIVE FROM
OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. IS
THAT THE CASE IN THIS ROOM WILL
WITNESSES APPEAR ON THAT SCREEN.
YES I WONDER OKAY. YEAH NOT
TONIGHT I BECAUSE I BY
PRESENTED IN A PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE THAT'S WHY I WAS
WONDERING WE'LL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY IN A BILL. CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO TWO. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY INSURANCE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU WERE
CALLING IN POLICE PLAN TO DO SO
IS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOUR SUPPORT WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A BILL.
IF YOU'RE HAVING A ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. TWO ZERO EIGHT SIX
AND MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO
TRY TO HELP YOU. WE'RE ALSO
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND- I THINK THAT
CONCLUDES THE REQUIRED LANGUAGE.
AND IS THERE A PARTICULAR ORDER
ON THIS AGENDA MR WRECKAGE. I'M
SORRY FOR WE NEED A QUORUM. AND
WE NOW HAVE IT LET'S TAKE ROLE.
IF IT WAS. THE PRESENT THE
PRESIDENT MAY PRESENT MAYES
PREFERENCE SHARES BIGELOW RIGHT
AROUND THE CORNER ON. ONE
HUNDRED TEN YEAR ROUND COOLEY.
BURKE FRAZIER GIPSON THERE IS A
PRESIDENT REYES AND- CONLOGUE
PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT WOULD
REFORM. GREAT AND- IS THERE AN
ORDER ON THIS AGENDA. TASHA'S
HERE FIRST LET'S TAKE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN TASHA BOERNER HORVATH
THIS IS AN I RECOMMENDATION BY
THE- FOR. THIS IS LIKE THIS IS
LIKE A BOBSLED TASHA I MEAN
THEY. EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY
THIRTY ONE. I HAVE NO FEAR.
OKAY CALIFORNIA OKAY DON'T JUST
TO HOLD. OKAY. CAN HELP. A
LITTLE. HI IT'S ME I DO COME UP
WITH. FOUR POINT ONE THOUSAND
ABOUT FOR THE. YEAH BUT- IF
JEFF GREEN. YES YOU SEE IS HE
PRESENT THE ON THE GO. I THINK
GO. THIS WOULD BE THE OP. FOR
DO WE NEED THE EIGHTEEN AS FAR.
ON SO I INTRODUCED TWO YEARS
AGO. GO AHEAD SIR X. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MY NAME IS STILL
WACHTER ON THE OF ECONOMICS AND
THAT ARE OF THE CALL POLICY
ALLOW. AT UCLA IT'S A PLEASURE
BE HERE AND I WAS ASKED TO BE
SHORT WHICH I'LL TRY TOUGH
BEING A PROFESSOR SO-
EXPEDITING WORK SHARING
APPLICATIONS AND INCREASING
OUTREACH TO EMPLOYERS AS
DISABILITIES COULD DO HAS CLEAR
BENEFITS FOR WORKERS EMPLOYERS
IN CALIFORNIA A WHOLE. WORK
SHARING INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
WORKERS THAT ARE EMPLOYED AND
IF I REDUCES THE COST OF LONG
TERM UNEMPLOYMENT WORK SHARING
ALSO HELPS MAINTAINING
ATTACHMENT BETWEEN WORKERS AND
FIRMS AND THIS PREVENTS WORKERS
FROM LOSING ACCESS TO GOOD JOBS
WHICH HAS BEEN FOUND TO BE A
KEY FACTOR IN THE COST OF
UNEMPLOYMENT. AND MOBILE UNDER
WORK SHARING WORKERS KEEP
RECEIVING HEALTH INSURANCE
BENEFITS THAT PUT THEM IN A
MUCH BETTER POSITION THAN
TEMPORARY LAYOFFS EMPLOYERS
BENEFIT AS WELL ESPECIALLY IN
THIS PROFESSION BECAUSE THEY
COULD REHIRE LAID OFF WORKER ON
A PART TIME YOU CAN WORKSHOPS
AND FINALLY. BY LIMITING
ONGOING LAYOFFS WORK SHARING
ALSO ALLOWS FOR A FASTER
RECOVERY BY REDUCING CROWDING
IN THE LABOR MARKET AND WE'RE
TRYING HAS FOR THIS REASON BOB
BY SUPPORT. THIS PARTICULAR
ADVANTAGE FROM ACTING NOW AN
ACTING DECISIVELY FIFTY COST TO
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY WORK
SHARING BENEFITS ARE ENTIRELY
PAID FOR BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND USING YOU AYE
RECORDS IN CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB DID SOME
APPROXIMATE CALCULATION THAT
YOU THAT THAT IF WE COULD RAISE
PARTICIPATION WORK SHARING
QUICKLY IT COULD BE SUBSTANTIAL
SAVINGS FOR THE WHITE TRUCK
PLANT WITH POTENTIAL BENEFICIAL
IMPLICATIONS FOR PAYROLL TAXES.
AND THE GENERAL TAXPAYER DOWN
THE LINE. OVERALL EXPEDITING
WORK SHARING UP TO AND- OUR TO.
THAT BILL KICKS DO IT FOR COULD
POPCORN AND GOOD GO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY SIR FOR THE
CONCERT. EXHORTATION
MISINFORMED FOUR OF US DO YOU
HAVE OTHER WITNESSES NO OKAY
LET'S I COULD HAVE OTHER
WITNESSES IF YOU WOULD LIKE ME
TO YOU KNOW MOVE NO NO IN THEM
IN THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED LET ME ASK THE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER PERSONS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE BILL YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
AND ARE THERE ANY PERSONS
WISHING TO SPEAK. IN OF
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I'M- I'M
SORRY SHARE THE I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT BRIEFLY IF I
MAY. RIGHT WHICH WOULD HELP
WHICHEVER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT MULTI. SURE EVERYTHING
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OF ANY
IN FAVOR. LARGE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE. ALL RIGHTS AND- ALL LAST
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR. TO
INVITE ANY OPPOSE STATEMENTS.
GIVE YOU BOTH OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL YOU MAY PRESS. ONE ZERO.
ONE ZERO UP IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. AND THERE IS NOBODY
IN Q. ALL RIGHT- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR. ALL RIGHT THIS MUST BE
FUN FOR YOU THIS MORNING OR THE
CORE OF US BECAUSE OF THE
GERMAN ROOTS OF THIS PROGRAM.
THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WEATHER
ECONOMIC TURNAROUNDS MUCH
BETTER BECAUSE OF WORK SHARING
SO THE MORE ROBUST WE MAKE IT
THE BETTER R. A. KHAN ARE THE
FASTER. AND MORE ROBUST OUR
ECONOMY WILL RECOVER I ENJOY
THE SENATE STAFF REPORT WHICH-
THE HISTORY OF THIS PROGRAM IN
GERMANY SO GOOD FOR YOU IT
LOOKS LIKE A IT'LL BE A REALLY.
A PRODUCTIVE PROGRAM- ASSUMING
IT BECOMES LAW. IT WE HAVE A
MOTION SECOND ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. LET'S
VOTE. DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES.
MAYES HI BERMAN. I BIGELOW
BIGELOW I CALDERON
COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER
FRAZIER GIPSON. GIPSON HI
GRAYSON. KAMLAGER IN ORDER AYE
VOEPEL WOULD. THAT'S A VOTE ALL
RIGHT THE BILL THIS BILL IS
PASSED. AND ALL INVITE MISS
GONZALEZ TO PRESENT HER BILL.
THIS WAS A GUT AND AMEND FROM
THE SENATE. COMING TO US FROM
THE SENATE MISTER CALDERON HAD
TO LEAVE AND HE MAY NOT BE BACK
FOR A WHILE SO ALASKA MARC TO
REMIND ME TO HOLD A HEARING
OPEN BECAUSE HE DOES WANT TO
ADD ON. WILL GROW. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GO AHEAD IT'S A GOT
A MENU MADE THAT SOUND SO DIRTY
AND OUT OF ORDINARY I SHALL
WRITE OR PRONOUNCE IT
DIFFERENTLY NEXT TIME. THE GUT
AND AMEND THANK YOU. IT'S A
GREAT. LOOK AT A NASHVILLE- IT
DID GO THROUGH THE SENATE. BUT
AT ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SIXTY SIX
IS AN EFFORT TO ENSURE
INDIVIDUAL UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CLAIMS ARE NOT
DELAYED SIMPLY BECAUSE THEIR
EMPLOYER HASN'T RESPONDED TO
ET'S INITIAL NOTICES. IT ALSO
ALLOWS ET DE TO DELEGATE THEIR
AUTHORITY TO RECOVER MISSING
YOU I CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE AG
FOR LARGE CORPORATIONS THAT
HAVE. THAT HAVE WORKERS
RECEIVING STATEWIDE BUT HAVE
NEVER PAID INTO THE FUND. THE
EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM
HAS BEEN A CRITICAL LIFELINE WE
KNOW DURING THESE TIMES MANY
WORKERS EVERY DAY WAIT TO GET
THROUGH EDT FOR THE U. I.
BENEFITS. IN EVERY DAY THEY
HAVE TO WAIT IS A DAY THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE MONEY TO PAY THE
RENT OR BUY FOOD. WE'VE HEARD
IN OUR OFFICES THE DELAY IS
OUTSTANDING. BUT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES STREAMLINE SOME OF THAT SO
HOPEFULLY DELETE SOME OF THOSE
DELAYS IT CODIFIES THE TEN DAY
DEADLINE FOR EMPLOYERS TO
RESPOND TO ET'S INITIAL NOTICE.
UNLESS THERE IS A GOOD CAUSE
FOR THAT DELAY THIS IS.
ALTHOUGH A NEW DEADLINE ALREADY
IN THE LITERATURE THAT IS SENT
TO EMPLOYERS THEY HAVE A TEN
DAY RESPONSE- REQUIREMENT IN
THE LITERATURE THAT THEY SENT.
ASSEMBLY INSURERS AND
INDIVIDUALS CLAIM WILL NOT BE
DELAYED IT JUST BECAUSE
EMPLOYER HAS NOT RESPONDED TO
ET'S INITIAL REQUEST FOR
INFORMATION. IN ADDITION AB TEN
SIXTY SIX WOULD ALLOW EACH
DELEGATE THEIR AUTHORITY TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO RECOVER
MISSING YOU I CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM LARGE CORPORATIONS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN PAYING THEIR FAIR
SHARE. RESPONSIBLE BUSINESSES
AND TAXPAYERS ARE SUBSIDIZING
COMPANIES ARE BREAKING THE LAW
BY NOT PAYING INTO YOU I FIND
WELL THERE WORKERS RECEIVE YOU
I BENEFITS. WHAT WE SAW DURING
THE GREAT DEPRESSION IS IT TOOK
TEN YEARS TO PAY OFF FOR YOU I
DEBT WE KNOWTHAT IN TWO YEARS
WE HAVE A FEDERAL LOAN THAT'S
GOING TO BECOME DEAL. AND THAT
THAT WILL HAVE TO BE PAID BY
LAW ABIDING BUSINESSES WHO HAVE
BEEN PAYING IN WE ALSO NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE GOING
AFTER THE COMPANIES WHO HAVE
NOT PAID IN AND TO RELEASE.
SOME OF THAT BURDEN SPECIALLY
OFF OF OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE DONE EVERYTHING
RIGHT. IT'S TIME WHEN ARE YOU
AYE. FUND IS BEING DEPLETED AB
TEN SIXTY SIX ONE SURE
CORPORATIONS THEIR FAIR. INSURE
THAT WORK GET THEIR THEIR
BETTER. IN A TIMELY MANNER AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR TIME BUT-
ALL RIGHT- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS BEFORE WE INVITE
PUBLIC COMMENT ANY QUESTIONS
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED I WILL ASK THE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR TO INVITE
SUPPORT COMMENT. GIVEN THE POOR
COMING YOU MAY PRESS. ONE ZERO.
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GET THE
PHONE LINE NUMBER. YOU AND WE
WILL GO TO A LINE OF NINETY
ONE. NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SERAPH LOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISS FLOCKS. OTHER OTHER
SUPPORT. COMMENTS THANK YOU. IT
IS ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. THERE
ARE NO WHEN Q. THANK YOU- WOULD
YOU INVITE ANY OPPOSE COMMENTS
PLEASE. MODERATOR IF YOU'RE NOT
IF YOU'RE NOT THE VISION OF
THIS BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. A MEASURE TO WELL-
WHICH COMPANY CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE I'D LIKE TO SPEAK I
THE PRINCIPLE I PROMISE TO BE
QUICK. GO AHEAD SIR. THANK YOU
GET RIGHT WHICH REPUBLICAN
CONGRESS YOUR POST BABY CAN'T
BE SICK- IS SIMPLY BECAUSE WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT BILL WILL
RESOLVE THE PROBLEM CITED THAT
MAY CREATE NEW ONES- I
APPRECIATE THE GRAVITY OF THE
AUTHOR AND ALL I WILLATTEMPT
TO MIRROR IT AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKEN ABOUT A GOOD
BET YOU GOT HIM. HOWEVER WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
BASICALLY IT IS POINTING IN THE
RIGHT BECAUSE WRECK NO EVIDENT
IN PLAYERS FAILING DELAYING AND
IN PROVIDING FORM CD ALREADY
HAVE IT THAT HAVE CAUSED YOU TO
BE SLOW WE'RE AWARE OF WHAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS SAID WHICH IS EASY
IT'S BEEN OVER WELL. TO THAT
END WE DON'T SEE THE TEN DAY
DEADLINE AND THE BILL HAS
CREATING ANY IMPROVEMENT IN
FACT EXISTING ET REGULATIONS
ALREADY DEFINED DEADLINES FOR
EACH FORM IN A VERY PRECISE
MANNER AND ALREADY CARRIED A
PUNISHMENT IF YOU FAILED TO
RESPOND YOU WILL PAY MORE
BENEFITS SO THAT ALREADY IN TAX
WE'RE CONSERVATIVE BILL ADDS A
LAYER OF VAGUENESS THAT THAT
MAY ACTUALLY. MAKE THE PROFIT
NOT WORK AS WELL ADMITTEDLY
IT'S NOT PERFECT BUT IT IT WILL
ONLY MAKE. IT MORE COMPLICATED.
ONE MORE GRIEF FOR AT FORMS
EVEN URGENT. NOW TO WEAR. RIGHT
AT THE END. OF A ONE FORM
EXAMPLE. IS A- AND TO READ. IF
THEY DON'T WANT TO CONTEST
BENEFITS SO. IF YOU. TO RESPOND
TO I THINK POINT AROUND. THAT
THE COURT RECORDS OR THE BACON
SO I WILL STOP THEIR- AND-
RESPECT THEY POSE A BECAUSE THE
KEYS. THANK YOU MISTER RUIZ.
OUR OTHER PERSONS WERE TO A.
KEEP IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. THERE
IS NO OTHER ONE THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT COMMITTEE MEMBERS ONE
MORE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS OR MAKE COMMENTS. MS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER IF YOU'D LIKE
TO THANK YOU KANYA I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
FRUSTRATION BY EVERYBODY BUT WE
KNOW FROM DOING CASE WORK THAT
OF BUSINESSES FAILURE TO
RESPOND ESPECIALLY WITH
MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS HAS IN
FACT LED TO DENIAL OF BENEFIT
OR PROLONGED- INVESTIGATION AND
A WAIT PERIOD. FOR EMPLOYEES
THAT NEED THOSE FUNDS THIS WILL
PUT A TIME CERTAIN DATE WHEN
THE EDT WILL STOP WAITING FOR
AN EMPLOYER TO RESPOND INSTEAD
START THE INVESTIGATION INTO
WHETHER NUMBER ONE THEIR
EMPLOYEE AND HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY MADE IT WON'T JUST BE A
FREE PASS TO. TO IT TO PAY OUT
FUNDS BUT IT ALLOWS ET DE TO
SAY ALRIGHT WE'VE GIVEN THEM
TIME WE'VE GOT TO MOVE ON
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
IN FACT I HAVE IN MY DISTRICT A
WOMAN WHO DIED- BECAUSE SHE
WENT BACK TO WORK BECAUSE HURT
HER FORM WAS NEVER FILLED OUT
IT WAS NEVER RETURNED- SHOULD
WAITED THREE MONTHS. FOR ET DE
TO DECIDE TO BEGIN THE WAGE
INVESTIGATION SHE WAS
MISCLASSIFIED I'M XIN OF
CONTRACTING COBIT AND DINE AND
SO LOOK WE HEAR THE STORIES I
KNOW ALL OF YOU HAVE HEARD THE
STORIES THIS JUST SETS A
TIMELINE IT SETS A TIMELINE SO
THAT HE CAN TELL US THEY'RE
JUST WAITING IT ALSO ALLOWS- I
AND I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT A FEW YEARS WE'RE ALL
GOING TO GRAPPLE WITH THE FACT
THAT PEOPLE HAVE NOT PAID INTO.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND
AS A RESULT IT'S UNDERFUNDED WE
KNOW FOR A FACT THERE ARE
COMPANIES THAT- THAT FIND OVER
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
WHAT WE BORROWED FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IT'S GOING
TO BECOME DEAL AND WE'RE ALL
GOING TO BE TRYING TO EXPLAIN
TO OUR MOM AND POP SHOPS IN OUR
DISTRICT WHY THEY'RE PAYING FOR
CORPORATIONS WHO NEVER PAID AND
THIS ALLOWS EIGHTY TO GO AFTER
THOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
TIME. GOOD THANK YOU- THERE'S A
MOTION AND SECOND ON. THIS BILL
I THINK WE SHOULD VOTE. THEY I
DALY I MAYES. MAYES NOT GOING
BERMAN BERMAN FIVE BIGELOW.
CALDERON CHEN. COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE COOPER FRAZIER
GIPSON- GIPSON HI GRAYSON.
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER FIVE VOEPEL
WOULD WOULD I'D. AT SIX VOTES
TWO FIVE SO FAR. AND THERE TO
MEMBERS OF THE WHO ARE ON THEIR
WAY BACK THANK YOU SO YOU'RE
WELCOME. OUR BUSINESS IS
FINISHED I'M GONNA HOLD HEARING
OPEN. ALL IN A LIVE THE CALL
FOR MR WILL. ON THAT PREVIOUS
BILL ON THE BOAT
BOERNER HORVATH MAYBE SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND WORKING.
WHAT IT ACTUALLY YEAH WHAT'S
YOUR CALDERON HI HI WHAT DOES
THAT HAS NOW TEN VOTES. THE
OTHER SO THAT WAS TEN SUCH. THE
OTHER FOR OF THE
BOERNER HORVATH BILL. HAS TEN
VOTE. AB TEN SIXTY SIX CALDERON
I CALLED HI GRAYSON GRAYSON HI
THAT HAS EIGHT VOTES. I THINK
IT COLUSA BUSINESS WE GAVE
EVERYONE A CHANCE TO ADD ON ANY
MARKERS OR ANYTHING ELSE THAT
WE NEED TO DO GO BACK. TO
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE. GRAYSON I
GRAYSON HIGH HAS ELEVEN VOTES.
THANK YOU ALL THANKS THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEE ON THE
FLOOR. THE THING ELSE OKAY.
RICHARD.